foreign
[Music]
each week we're going to discuss a topic
which we think hasn't got enough pickup
in the national press and this week we'd
like to talk about the Online safety
Bill and it was introduced 12's work
started on it several years ago and
Theresa May was all set to introduce it
then Nadine Doris was a champion of it
Russian neck changed it has decided to
still go ahead is it still a threat to
free speech is it still a threat to the
Free Press as editor of The Spectator I
have argued that it is but one of the
most articulate Defenders of the pill is
Damian Collins who former Tech Minister
who joins me now Damien welcome thank
you
um now you you say that I agree with you
that that the the tech we're in a
strange situation with tech companies
have created the public space so now
when people are having a debate
increasingly they're having a debate on
forums which were created and are owned
by the likes of Facebook by YouTube I'd
discussions happening on YouTube whether
somebody's watching it right now will
depend on whether it was recommended by
YouTube now what discomforts me as an
editor is I noticed all the time that
how much a fortunes change depending on
the content for example if you and I
were to discuss
um the safety of vaccines that would
immediately flag it up to the YouTube as
a potentially dodgy conversation and
perhaps our viewers would be far less
likely to see it so I've noticed the
real power but these digital companies
have
um in basically deciding who watches
what people assume their Facebook feeds
are are curated by the people they
follow but no Facebook decides or edits
so they've got more power than a Murdoch
than a Hearst than a
um Beaver Brook amazing power
what nerves me is the idea that
government might be directing these guys
so you get big Tech Plus big government
to put together a kind of power
composure which
could be open to abuse well I think
you're right to raise it and um because
if you go back to the days of Lord
northcliffe where he printed a third of
the newspapers read in London every
morning with Prince on his presses well
two-thirds weren't and if you went to a
newsstand you could you had a choice of
what you got if your news feed in on on
next up on YouTube or on Facebook or
wherever whichever social app you use is
largely directed by recommendation and
that recommendation steers you largely
towards the same thing that gives
immense power to the people who have
those recommendations we're talking
billions aren't we we're not talking
about the north you'd be lucky to have a
couple of millions but the people who
really think Facebook is now the number
one provider of the recent written news
in Britain after the broadcasters
absolutely and you see you look at all
the data that shows I say younger
audiences but I mean people under the
age of 40 not just you know students or
younger people than that they're
principally getting their news from
social media they're not even going to a
News website uh to get news that's been
edited for them so the role of the news
editor in determining the issues they
thought were important the priority they
attached to them the way they were laid
out that is bypassed by an algorithm so
we should be concerned around the power
that lies behind that algorithm and how
it's directed and how that is
influencing the way people see the news
and the world around them so tell me
what the Online safety bill would do for
this would it offer any transparency
with this process well it it does I
think two quite important things
one is it says for news with regards to
news providers it says to the big
Platformers it can't be right that you
YouTube are effectively the
editor-in-chief for every news
organization that distributes its
content through your platform which
means that your platform policies set
effectively editorial standards so if
they're they're publishing story you
don't like you can either kick it off
the platform or you can downgrade it an
orphan with no explanation I mean we
once said I call them as Lionel Shriver
read out her column on YouTube and we
found it demonetized it was targeted by
their Bots and it was very difficult to
find out why I think David Davis gave a
speech uh protesting against
um
vaccine
um it was awesome it was the lockdown
measures and that was taken down by
YouTube so again amazing power just to
blackball this that and the other I'm
going to talk radio there's a case of
talk radio
um they had a show that they podcast on
YouTube and the whole channel was taken
down because YouTube disagreed with it
it was restored as David Davis's speech
was
course surely is still in place with the
Online safety so what the Online safety
Bill does though it says to the
platforms you can't interfere with news
publisher content
for unless you've given that news
company the right to appeal against a
decision you might make so you could
have a month of an appeal process
whereby for the news company even if
they lose the appeal that the currency
of that news item is still is still
valid but we can appeal at the moment we
do we lose but we appeal but at the
moment that you will face arbitrary
takedown so they will just remove but
you have no right to appeal what the
Online safety bill says is the company
can't remove unless they've gone through
an appeal process so that everything
isn't the trick though I mean it's
interesting to see what we're talking
about here there are many ways in which
you can be penalized now very seldom as
a spectator article removed or is it one
of our podcaster videos removed all that
happens is that we can notice that it's
got far fewer hits and that's because
it's been targeted in a way that we
don't understand now YouTube huge
amounts of power comes on what to watch
next so people might be watching our
discussion on YouTube right now Libby
said you might want to read a b and c
next huge amounts of power something
YouTube doesn't favor it won't be taken
down it just won't be recommended but
there's nothing really to in the bill to
increase the transparency over that is
there well so I think this is another I
think this is a really really important
issue and it's not one that is directly
addressing the Online safety bill but I
hope we'll be addressed in the digital
markets bill that the government is
going to bring forward in this session
so that's been brought forward because I
think here you get into a really
interesting area that a number of news
Publishers have been complaining about
which is that do recommendation tools on
Google or YouTube or on Facebook do this
into recommend they listen to prioritize
some news organizations over others you
know why is it that some always seem to
be in your stream of recommended content
but not others or some lines of argument
over others I mean that's my broader
concern because if you're in the opinion
of in the business of against the Green
journalism as The Spectator it has been
since 1828 that's when the Bots are more
likely to to spot you if you're simply
reinforcing the consensus the Bots don't
go against you but if for example you
you you're saying something about
um I'll give you a very good example
when we permissions and Professor Carl
Hennigan from Oxford to write an
assessment of the science over face
masks now Facebook
um slapped in the label on there saying
um false information now Facebook to
this day will refuse to tell us why they
put that label on it and which to me is
quite amazing if I'm publicly including
you false information then a matter of
decency you'd expect me to say why I
think you're false but but Facebook
doesn't do that
um but the thing is as far but you say
that you might but you might hope to get
this in a second bill but the Online
safety bill doesn't do any of this I
mean I tell you what my concern about it
is this is happening this bill has been
the Online safety bill is what is it
four years in the making yes yeah yeah a
long time yeah during those four years
Technologies advance so much
that the threats we're talking about now
simply isn't addressed and in fact you
guys might make it worse because you're
you're you what you're doing in this
bill is you're saying to the online
company that we will give ourselves
Parliament the ability to find you
what's up to 10 of global turnover which
is billions upon billions of dollars
so that will make them intrinsically
risk-averse and more likely to block or
downgrade arguments that go against the
grain well I disagree with that but I
want to come back for that but if I can
just go back to what you made it's a
short moment ago which is to say uh in
terms of like news publisher content so
there will be some protections there for
news Publishers which don't currently
exist the other thing the platforms will
have to do is demonstrate how they give
due regard for freedom of expression in
the in the decisions they make over
moderating content do you regard yeah so
so they'll have to demonstrate to the
regulator have they considered well if
this if this content there's no legal
requirement why it should be removed if
it's not in breach of the platform's
terms of service yet they're still
downgrading it why are they doing that
and so there will be trans to your point
about what sort of transparency will
there be of con can demand transparency
on that but with the phrase do you
regard it's a joke isn't it it's
meaningless well no I don't think it is
because what it'll do it will bring
transparency there is none at the moment
because there's Eagle self said you've
got no rights or no way of knowing why
they're making these decisions well
ofcom can expose that I think there is a
question for the bill all as to what
power should ofcom have to intervene
where companies are removing content
where they've never said they would
remove it there's no reason why they
should and yet they're doing it anyway
and at the moment we have no
transparency over that and the bill will
give us some transparency how will they
give you transparency because as far as
I'm aware see our conversation now gets
thumbs down from the YouTube Bots or the
algorithms YouTube is not a new
obligation at all to tell us this and
under the legislation it will also be
under no obligation to tell us we would
only know when we find out that our
conversation has got a fraction of a
traffic but it normally does what I'm
saying is you verbally here you see you
recognize the problem but the bill will
do nothing to oblige social media
companies to inform the Publishers when
it is punished targeted or downrighted
their contest well often often can ask
of that information off comic of course
the regulator will have the right to
challenge companies on that to say are
they are they regulate are they making
interventions to prevent content going
going via reaching the audience it
should naturally reach course they are
we're doing that on a minute several
thousand times a day well they're
they're under there are two there are
two things that play there there is the
recommendations they make you know um
there's also the way I think external
organizations can gain content on the
platforms as well and then you see a lot
of activity you know through bot
accounts seeking to drown out legitimate
content in the news and promote other
content often often fake content to
drown out other sorts of news as well
now there's a question about what sort
of action do the platforms take to try
and protect the quality of the
information that circulates on their
platforms and when you talk to
journalists like Maria ressa you know
working in the Philippines this is the
biggest problem that she faces and her
big concern that if we don't regulate
that legitimate journalism gets drowned
out is that it's less then it's not just
about what the platforms do it's about
the fact that the manipulation of
thousands and thousands millions of fake
accounts are actually changing what
people see and you can just take
legitimate journalism and bury it under
a pile of that's not really happening it
might be happening in the Philippines
but it's not really happening in Britain
I think rather I think less so in
Britain thank God is
around sort of algorithmic preference it
works two ways there's are companies
making decisions to deliberately
downgrade content of why they're doing
that at the moment as you said we have
no transparency the bill will give off
on the power to find out and and to
determine that and that works for
Freedom expression and principally I
mean the core objective is actually
working to deal with you know content
that is that is illegal content that is
you know because of the nature of its
illegality will cause harm as well but
you said earlier on that you were
concerned that there was a con if we set
these standards if we start saying to
tech companies if you don't remove this
this sort of content that's illegal then
we're going to find you and you're they
will just remove more and more yeah well
I actually think what we should do in
this space is to say Well they're the
standards of of how platforms are
regulated the standards that determine
the things that they allow and they
don't allow shouldn't just rest on
arbitrary decision on their point or
their own terms of service what we
should do is say we have legal standards
for many for many a couple of many areas
of speech so things that incitement and
racial hatred is a criminal offense you
know we have an incitement of violence
you know is is a criminal offense people
are prosecuted for these things the
minimum safety standards you set should
be based on our laws if you set higher
standards to yourself then you should be
held to account for whether you enforce
them or not and where our Regulators
have the right to know how you do it and
why you do it now the right to produce
data from the company so if a company
promises that it won't allow hate speech
on its platform well actually how does
it determine what hate speech is and how
does it enforce those rules well tell us
what how does the how is it defined in
the legislation well the legislation
will take the minimum safety standard is
based on the legal threshold so if you
take race hate and I think the case
that's often cited in this debate around
the the race hate that was directed
towards the England footballers after
the final of the European championships
now there you people were prosecuted for
what they posted on on Twitter and
Instagram we've got an established case
law where we know what the minimum legal
standard is we know where the
intervention should come so we say to
the platforms what the bills access to
the platforms is your safety standards
should at least be set at that level you
should be looking to proactively
identify that sort of behavior and
mitigating it but what happens if there
are unintended casualties of this
well they have the platforms are not
required to go above that they may set
higher than they will and what happens
when they do what happens when they take
away legitimate comments because they've
misdiagnosed something as well if that
happens that's far more likely to happen
because it's their own they're enforcing
their own terms of service in most cases
I would say the terms of service of the
platforms probably sit above the legal
threshold right so because minimum the
minimum standard should be based on our
laws and there should be proper
enforcement at that because my concern
would be most of the time the companies
say they will do things in the terms of
service and they just don't do them
right but you're coming at this thinking
okay by the way every time there's a
restriction of free speech it always
starts off with an example nobody could
argue again so nobody would think this
should be a vile racism online nobody
thinks you promote terrorism or buying
guns or buying drugs Etc but the next
thing you know Nadine Doris is talking
about the jokes of Jimmy Carr as you
mentioned that in House of Commons as
being something she would like to to
take action against um you yourself have
mentioned Andrew Tate as being something
that tell us about entertained well so I
think the concern with Andrew Tate is
whether not just the content he's
publishing but content that he's a
movement of people that he's that really
is around him are promoting I think
misogynistic attitudes towards young
boys young teenage boys and the the
concern here is it's not just what it's
not just it's what you really started
with it's about the preponderance of
content as well so so for children in
particular which is where the the
principal concern around agitate has
been raised is are children seeing a
preponderance of content from him which
actually is in breach of the community
standards and could be harmful to
children and therefore what sort of
intervention is harmful what sort of
intervention do we make at that point I
think it's important to you to say
because harmful is a test would you
intend to apply uh you and you social
media companies are threatened with huge
fines that they get this wrong so when
you say Andrew Tate is coming with
harmful content if I'm YouTube and
thinking okay you intend to find me I'll
take a bit seriously but please Mr
Collins tell me give me example of what
Mr Taylor said that is harmful yeah so
the decisions we made at the moment on
with regards to Andrew Tate have not
been made as a consequence of the Online
safety Bill they're decisions that the
platforms themselves have made because
they think his content breaches their
community staff but you you seem to have
a problem with Andrew's hits well I I
think the idea of a problem with Andrew
takes content particularly as it's been
I think directed at scale
um been promoted at scale by platforms
to to children and that's would your
legislation change this when I said the
legislation sets requires of com to work
with the companies to determine what are
the safety standards they set for
children which could be different for
adults and unlike with adults there are
risk assessments of that content so we
get data and information we can see what
the companies are doing what decisions
they're making but I've always taken The
View with the bill and in the long
gestation period of this piece of
legislation the sort of four years the
thing I've urged for constantly I think
has happened is to for us to be far more
specific about what it is we want the
companies well can you give us then a
specific can you can you give a single
example of what Undertaker said that you
wouldn't want a child to hear well no so
I think with with Andrew Tate at the
moment is principally around the
companies the platform the platform
policies the company set for themselves
right but they'll be wondering what you
mean by this I mean so I've got a
teenage boy he's 15 years old what is it
that Andrew Tate says that you think you
shouldn't be hearing well I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna have a list of everything
Andrew Tate or his followers have said
I'm saying that you're proposing passing
a law though right you know that that
would put social media companies on the
hook if it no then they'll be left
wondering what do the politicians mean
by this but when they try to find out
all of a sudden it gets very vague yeah
so I think no not at all that's why I
said if you look at the the legal
standards we want to set what we've done
is bring on to the face of the bill
they'll say well if we're saying there
are there are things that are a breach
of our laws that we want the companies
to apply what are those laws so on the
face of the bill now is written those
offenses those League those priority
legal offenses that exist for all adults
and that's that is a far wider range of
specific offenses than was there before
you know so a matter I think gives a lot
more clarity as to which offenses are we
talking about how might they be enforced
well say for example the bringing in uh
the bringing in inciting racial hatred
bringing in harassment where we have
legal case law that's set set on the
statute books the courts have
interpreted it we said these are the
safety standards so where companies see
content like that their their obligation
their duty is not to mitigate it and up
front they will agree with the regulator
codes of practice where they agree they
say well these are the standards we will
set this is how we interpret what the
law says here are in addition to that
our community standards this is what we
will do and that's agreed up front with
the regulator it's laid in front of
Parliament and that is the basis of
Regulation but more than that well
ofcommon's got the power to do then is
to go into the companies and say well
show us you're doing it we want
information to say how do you police
this how do you enforce it how do you
make sure that you're not over enforcing
you're not removing stuff where you've
got no right to be removing it because
it's not a legal requirement it's not or
it's not your platform policy that is
the framework within this world so I
think like what that gives us is two
things much more certainty on what it's
based on codes of practice where it's
written down in terms of exactly what
will happen and these are these are
based on our laws without our regulator
overseeing them rather than just being
arbitrary decisions someone in Silicon
Valley makes where we've got no idea how
they make that decision or how they
enforce it or if they enforce it right
but let's okay though I do notice that
Andrew Tate seems to be your Jimmy Carr
because you know you don't like him very
much I get that you can't name a single
thing you've done that you think would
transgress any law right now not just
that any sort of decency boundary that
you might want to the social media
companies to enforce and that's the
problem isn't it they have to guess now
let's take my colleague Ron little are
you familiar with this Uber oh yeah
right now he did a DNA test recently and
he hoped he'd be 90 English and 10
Viking he had hoped in fact it turns out
he's mostly Scottish now he took quite
badly to this and he wrote a column
about this he said um isn't this
terrible he said I turn out to be
majority
um salad dodging smack head that's how
he described Scott like me was that race
8 well I don't think I mean people might
not like it but anything that is that is
racy but you can see how that might get
judged by a bot
can't you well so
I think what you mean by that is if a
company if the platforms say well
you know we don't like that content
therefore we're either going to
downgrade it so no one sees it or we're
going to remove it all together
what the Online safety pool does there
is to say we save the companies they say
well you're making that decision on what
basis are you making it is it in
breaching your community standards the
company they've got a right to set
standards if they want to but how do I
know say I published this and and I find
out that Rod has referred to my fellow
Scots and did hear me Scottish himself a
salad dodging smack heads not very
polite uh but they've taken it down but
I don't know that as a publisher yeah
that's why that's why we have the
publisher exemption which I think is
important because what you do as an
editor is you put your name to
everything that you publish you are the
person who is liable and responsible for
those decisions you make so if someone
doesn't if you if you publish something
that someone takes great exception to
they can take you to court that's the
decision you take and that's why we
don't want to take that power away from
from editors we want to protect editors
to carry on making those decisions the
vast majority of the content that we we
talk about often online is being illegal
well particularly the stuff that is
illegal the reason the Online safety
bill is important is that those people
don't have the the liability you have
they're not putting their name to what
they say they're not traceable they may
be out of jurisdiction and that was what
the bill is really saying is we're
recognizing that actually the platforms
have a responsibility and have a
liability because they're the ones that
are actually promoting this content to
other people and they're doing it to
make money Damian Collins thank you very
much for joining me on the view from 22.
thank you
[Music]